foreign
Pennsylvania and talk to Aaron what's up
Aaron
yep how are you doing John awesome man
how are you
good good what's up
well I'm not sure how to uh
uh move through move forward with my
parents or work through things or not
work through things
um
uh there's always been a level of
controlling-ness with them and things
have just kind of escalated out of
control in the last little over a year
um I mean we've had different issues
throughout I've been married for 11
years we've had different issues that
entire time I mean things have been good
and then every couple years find out
something's not good give me an example
how's it how's it impacting you guys
directly
came to the place that we told my
parents we need
we need
um for like six months we don't want any
contact what happened what led up to
that
your actually in relationship to my
sister
um some things that
they did with her
um she was getting married and they yeah
just some of the things they did to her
um bro you're being so vague I can't
help you're just like circling Way High
oh man
um I mean it's a huge step for somebody
to say I'm Mom and Dad I'm cutting y'all
off for six months you cannot
communicate with me or my new family
because of something you have done or
continue to do over time that's a huge
step so what's the thing that happened
what'd they do to your sister
um so
uh there was just yeah
it's just stupid stuff
what what I'm gonna start making stuff
up the either either they set the bridal
party on fire as they were walking out
and they're like like a horror movie or
it was like The Shining or or they just
didn't get the right flowers like me
like
what happened
well they were stuff in regards to the
the finances for the wedding they
couldn't agree on finances you know
started setting things off and then
um she brought up some things from her
her past with a boyfriend that they they
were really liked
um and you know made some accusations as
far as some abuse there and
um they basically told her we don't
believe you
um so that was what really set me off um
and then when we did support her uh we
started getting the cold shoulder we
started getting the nasty comments
and all that kind of stuff
um give me an example of a nasty comment
and uh you know I was like Hey like I'm
just trying to support her I'm not
picked inside and uh they're like no
well you have to pick a side
what
and it's not you know you know the last
time that happened to me fifth grade
fifth grade when someone's like you
either with us or you're not
um sounds like your parents are very
very immature
is that fair
yeah and it sounds like it's you and
your sister grow up and develop their
adult y'all's adulthood and your own
autonomy that they are losing a course
into their identity which is we run the
show in these two kids lives
is that fair yes okay so you tell your
parents
they came over to your house like with a
demand letter basically saying it's
either us or your sister and by the way
any family member that ever did that to
me I would do exactly what you did and I
would say you've just opted out of
relationship with me because I don't
interact with adults that act like
four-year-olds Bye Felicia right and so
I would have done the same thing
as a six months passed
uh no that's been about two months ago
um
[Applause]
yeah I mean conversations had gone
nowhere there was yeah just manipulation
working around topics so I took him up a
letter and said hey like we need we need
this and this way we can't
have this conversation get turned around
um so they sent me a letter about three
weeks ago and said hey like we really
want to fix things
don't know what to do do I go back you
know and try and have another
conversation or is that just making
continuing the cycle
um
I have a core Rule and it's this I only
speak if I can be heard
and so if I see a loved one A friend of
mine just doing something so dumb with
their money
right they're just acting like idiots
or a buddy I don't have any friends like
this but let's pretend I did like I had
a buddy that was like man I've really
met this girl and we're kind of like
we're not hooking up or like we go have
drinks once a week or something like
that and he's married to a friend of
mine
um
I
if they say hey man what do you think
about that
or am I crazy bro you just opened the
door like a vampire and invited me in
I'm coming in I'm Gonna Give You full
picture but if you're being done with
your money and you don't ask my I'm not
just gonna start I'm just not gonna
start
giving you wisdom or advice or what I
think is the right thing to do I used to
do that all the time and I
um almost became abusive with that
and so that's why even on this show I
wait till people call me and then they
call me and then I'm like all right I'll
tell you what I actually think about it
and so if you think you could sit down
with your mom and dad
and you talk and they would listen
and you were able to say
my sister your daughter came to you and
said I got I was abused either
emotionally or physically or sexually
and y'all sided with her old
ex-boyfriend
and when she reached out for somebody
and I as her brother stepped up
you made me pick sides
I don't do that
and so if you ever want to re-engage
with us you have to choose to never
again put me in a position where I'm
gonna have to choose sides between my
mom and dad and my sister not gonna do
that
and if you think they could hear that
conversation and I'm sure there's a host
of other things that y'all need to talk
through right
um because how did you say it um
they said some things and actually they
got in their car and drove over to your
house and said you have to cut your
sister out and shun her to Dwight
Schrute style or right like that's
that's more than just saying some things
right so I I know that this has been
bigger issues if you think they could
hear it I don't have a problem with
having another conversation but that
conversation needs to be something that
you've written down and that you read to
them and they commit to listening and
not responding before you get finished
okay if you think in your heart they're
not going to listen to anything they
never have for 30 years they've never
listened they're not going to listen now
then
you don't even have to respond to the
letter because you've given them a
boundary and that's in six months we'll
reconvene
so cool in six months um I'll write them
back and say I got your letter thank you
for sending it period
that's it sometimes when somebody puts a
big strong boundary it can be
manipulative to throw a
um
woe is me please forgive me or they
didn't even ask for forgiveness but a
woe is me I want to fix this grenade
over the wall of your boundary hoping
you'll pick it up
and at least send a text because if you
send a text now we got a little crack in
right
what does your gut tell you
my gut tells me there that nothing's
changed
um go with your gut go with your gut
yeah I mean my thoughts were like I gave
you enough stuff to apologize for like
if there was a you know if there was a
tink in your armor if there was you know
a softening of your heart whatever like
you know you just said something either
you know apologize for something
apologize or whatever and I didn't see
any of that yeah
um if somebody sends you a note that
says we need to fix this I really want
to fix this and it doesn't include an
apology
then they're going to want you to
tell them you're sorry and fix all the
stuff
but at the end of the day
they opted out of relationship with you
by forcing you to choose between you and
your sister which is just insane and
um
you called their Bluff and you put up a
boundary good for you I'm really proud
of you man I'm really proud of you
um but if your gut says man they're not
going to listen they're not going to
hear a word I say then I say save your
breath save your breath are you going to
feel guilty yes are you going to be sad
that your parents act like they're so
mature like that yes are you going to be
heartbroken that your parents won't uh
forgive you I mean won't ask for
forgiveness yes don't apologize yes
it doesn't mean it's not the right thing
to do it's hard but doesn't mean it's
not the right thing to do I'm proud of
you man probably for protecting your
family I'm proud of you for sticking by
your sister even when it was hard and
you defaulting to belief over accusation
more women need men in their lives that
default to belief and
um
man I'm proud of you for not just
getting sucked right back into the
Vortex when your parents wrote you some
mushy letter without an apology in it
good for you ma'am good for you hard
hard adult stuff
and I wish it was different
but we gotta choose reality right and
I'm proud of you proud of you